this is curtin divina reading for
reviewer richard wakeling
nlb the show 21 maintains the series's
high bar of excellence once the ball's
in play
away from the diamond however there are
a number of missing features and
questionable decisions that take some of
the shine of an otherwise fantastic game
of baseball
and a backflip amongst the flashing
lights
the card collecting mode diamond dynasty
is the basis for most of these dubious
decisions
particularly in regards to road to the
show
mlb the show 21's career mode still
revolves around the core idea of
creating a player and taking them from
the minor leagues through to the majors
but the structure of the mode has been
significantly reworked
your creative ballplayer is now a single
unified entity
this ballplayer with all the
improvements you make to their
attributes
also carries over into diamond dynasty
where they can be inserted into the
starting lineup alongside current
players
and legends of the sport it's a solid
idea on paper but the execution
severely hampers road to the show in a
few major areas
for one having a single ball player
limits your options since you're unable
to create more than one distinct
character
you can still create multiple saves to
make characters who play in different
positions but you're stuck
using the exact same player in each on
top of this
there's also a new loadout system that
allows you to create multiple custom
loadouts
each one features one main archetype and
up to two perks that improve
certain attributes while slightly
decreasing others this change appears to
be geared towards another new addition
which gives you the option to play as a
two player similar to shohei otani
for games when you're hitting and
playing on field you might select a
loadout with perks based on improving
your contact
power and arm accuracy on days when
you're pitching
you might opt for another loadout with
pitching centric perks
again this is a decent idea on paper but
the execution is once again lacking in a
number of key areas
attributes still improve during the
process of playing games and completing
training drills during your off days but
natural progression like this is
exceedingly slow to the point where it
feels like it barely has an impact
loadouts and equipment offset this
meager progression by pumping up the
numbers but it's difficult to feel any
attachment to your created player
when you have next to no palpable input
on how they improve
of course you can purchase perks and
equipment from the in-game marketplace
either by using stubs earned by playing
or by using real money to bypass this
entirely
the series has always been relatively
generous when it comes to handing out
rewards
and mlb the show 21 is no different but
introducing microtransactions into a
single player mode is still a
cynical maneuver that might also explain
part of the reason why
year to year saves are absent when it
comes to diamond dynasty there's an if
it ain't broke
don't fix it approach this year the
time-consuming mode is still
bulging at the seams with various
challenges and different ways to play
whether you're recreating famous moments
with legends of the past
stealing fans from other teams in
conquest or simply competing against
other players online
the same can also be said of franchise
mode only the dearth of
updates in this case is disappointing
trade logic has been improved and the
addition of yearly depth chart gives you
a clear outline of how your team might
develop in which areas will eventually
need reinforcements
budgets have also been streamlined so
that they're now readable
making it easier to plan ahead but
franchise is still missing a number of
key
features that are mainstays in other
sports games such as
online franchise expansion teams and
league realignments like road to the
show year-to-year saves are also absent
in franchise
as well so you won't be able to carry
over 10-year orioles rebuild from the
previous games
sounds of the show is another feature
that was lost in the move to newer
consoles
meaning there's no way to import custom
music or
better walk-ups and so on commentary is
also behind the times there are a couple
of new commentary lines and road to the
show relating to
two-way players but otherwise the
three-man booth is
overly familiar at this point it's the
first one of the day if he's going to
exit
he jumps on this one it's high and deep
to center
a leap at the wall but forget it it's
gone a home run
[Applause]
mlb the show has always been one of the
better looking sports games
so the increase in graphic fidelity on
playstation 5 isn't a significant leap
lighting has been improved and managers
in particular
look more lifelike than before the
addition of hundreds of new animations
has a much more discernible impact on
the visuals though
adding to the game's fluidity and sense
of realism the ps5 controller's haptic
feedback is also utilized in good effect
sending vibrations through your hands
that mimic the ball careening off the
end of the bat
or nestling in a fielder's glove the oft
requested stadium creator also finally
makes its series debut
letting you build ghastly monstrosities
from the ground up recreate
famous ballparks or add your own
personal touch
to a selection of pre-built stadiums the
only negative right now is you can't
play night games in creative stadiums
but this is expected to be introduced in
a later patch
pinpoint pitching is the headline new
feature once you step out into the
diamond
as the name implies this is a new
pitching interface with an emphasis on
precision
obviously how precise you are depends on
your ability to successfully execute on
this new mechanic
and it's the most challenging pitching
interface in the game
once you've picked the pitch type and
its placement you need to use the right
analog stick to accurately trace a
pattern
that's dictated by your pitch selection
timing is crucial
as you're either rewarded or penalized
for being too fast or too slow
there's definitely a steep learning
curve to mastering pinpoint pitching but
is tactile and feels very natural to
pull off as though
you're mirroring the player's pitching
motion it won't be for everyone and the
series has never forced players into
using a particular system
so you can still stick to meter pitching
or another interface if need be
it's a solid new addition though and
adds another wrinkle to the show's
on-field quality
fielding has also been improved via more
fluid animations
and better indicators check swings are
also
entirely based on player skill now
removing the element of randomness
that was present before even if the
player discipline attribute had an
impact whether you hold up on a swing or
not is predicated on your ability to
quickly cancel out of it this is bound
to be a divisive change
considering it results in more
strikeouts but favoring skill
over an element of luck is a positive
change much like its predecessors
mlb the show 21 is still one of the best
sports games available once you step
over the foul line the gameplay has been
tightened up and pinpoint pitching is a
potential game changer and all of these
elements
go some way to dampening the
disappointment of its missing features
stale commentary and changes or lack
thereof
to road to the show and franchise
it's not the strongest debut the series
could have had on new hardware
but if you're in the mood for nine
innings of america's favorite pastime
mlb the show is still the undisputed
king
there's a swing and a missile sent out
to center field
and goodbye this one ain't coming back
[Music]
[Music]
you